Could we survive without rulers? Without
the state?
We have survived for centuries despite them and they're destructive wars and stifling oppression.
Crippling taxes suck half our wealth away
sprinklings just a fraction back.
It has been done before. Archaeology shows some of our ancestors living in peace
for a few thousand years before armed
rulers appear on the scene.
Not in caves, but in cities with tens of thousands enjoying civilisation we would recognise.
What would life be like without the
state?
Less complicated, divisive and confusing for a start.
Poverty would be slashed with half our wealth back in circulation
and none wasted on wars and
political schemes.
Enterprise and innovation flourish without the regulation that favours large corporations.
We do things voluntarily,
never because we are threatened
with damage for non-compliance. It is a
climate in which our cooperative and
charitable nature can flourish. When join
up in a free system we find effective
ways to meet our community's needs. We
develop systems in which cream rises to
the top, instead of scum.
Online vendors value their reputations.
The states only vital function is
protecting us from other versions of itself.
Everything else we could do
ourselves. We could even develop a less
rigid justice system with no victimless offenses,
that benefits from a reduction in crime and fear.
We could deter, punish and protect with levels of digital exile tailored to the offense.
Jails are just so last century.
Civilisation developed through the connection and cooperationof people.
We are more connected now than at any time in human history.
We have the tools to develop structures that self-govern from the bottom up,
evolving as times change.
Could we survive a crash of the global banking system
and the nation states they underwrite?
We could survive and eventually thrive!